hey everyone and welcome to another
episode of good news gaming the show
that highlights all the good and fun
stuff from the week in games just like
this absolutely impeccable comic timing
in GTA online
[Music]
this week I'm obviously very excited
about all the Series X news to come out
of inside Xbox hence my Phil Spencer
shrine I guess in the backgrounds but in
the good news this week the fallout 76
community have come together for a
really incredible gesture friend CJ
Martin Fairchild is a really famous role
player in fallout 76 he acts as a doctor
in the wasteland patching people up when
they need it and actually before the
game added NPC's in the wasteland as
update brent was basically role playing
as one because he was providing help to
people along with tidbits of law and
even quests but unfortunately on May 2nd
he was hurt in a fire at his home and he
suffered from severe burns
so the Fallout community have started a
GoFundMe to help raise money for his
home repairs while he's in hospital I'll
obviously link it below but best wishes
to him and he is hoping for a speedy
recovery now I love me some Animal
Crossing and I know a lot of you do too
but I think we can all agree that some
of the game could be a bit more
streamlined so Nick ha on YouTube has
made a fake Nintendo Direct with all the
quality of life improvements that I
think we're all really hoping that
Nintendo will add to the game like
crafting multiples of one item a quick
sort for your pockets a button to hurry
through dialogue you've heard before and
my favorite improvements to online play
obviously this direct is totally fake
and it's not really good news because
it's not been confirmed by Nintendo that
they're making any of these changes yet
but I thought it was something to
highlight because it's so well made it
is packed full of jokes about Animal
Crossing and little sight gags that you
have to pause to read so it's incredibly
well made and I really really hope
Nintendo we're watching and while we're
on the subject of animal crossing i read
a wild article on polygon this week
about animal crossing fans getting in
trouble because of weed or should I say
weeds Facebook seems to think that these
fan groups are talking about openly
selling the drug marijuana when in
reality it's just animal crossing
players trading in-game weeds for
crafting there are also other
unconfirmed
reports that Facebook doesn't like here
when people talk about trading
molly-molly
is an adorable duck villager in Animal
Crossing who just happens to share their
name with another drug so in order to
combat this and get on Facebook's good
side these fan groups are asking people
to not use terms like weed and Molly and
be more creative by using things like
gardening tidying and wild flowers
anyway I just thought this was a really
weird story this week and the whole time
I was writing this script for today I
had this vine going around in my head so
here you go no this is a crayon okay so
here's a few cool things that I've seen
on the web this week let's kick off with
Richard Perry's incredible photography
series we all know the curves and the
feel of our favorite controllers but
this series disassembles them in such a
cool and interesting way this image of a
360 controller for example is made up of
a hundred and forty pictures and after
seeing this one on Reddit I did a bit
more digging and found not only his
Instagram page which is amazing and I'll
link it below but an old verge article
about just how these pictures are made
and I think one of the really cool
takeaways is that Richard learned how to
do all of this himself by using YouTube
he also says that he hasn't tried to
reassemble any of them which given how
many pieces they're rolling at the end
is probably wise i bloodied love a good
video essay so I really have to
recommend this one by Jacob Geller if
you're a big fan of games like resident
evil Silent Hill and the evil within and
their soundtracks this deep dive into
why horror games sound so beautiful is
an absolute must watch it's a super
thought-provoking video about a subject
that I've never really given much
thought to and I really recommend
setting aside half an hour and giving it
a watch this is kind of a random one but
I think it's a really cool and weird
story so target game footage from a
cancelled Prince of Persia game was
found on YouTube recently but the weird
thing is that footage has been up on
YouTube for eight years and no one
noticed so in case you're wondering if
it's fake or not well Jonathan Cooper
who is game animator on titles like The
Last of Us part
to mass effect and Assassin's Creed 3
actually commented on Twitter that this
footage is legitimate and was what
inspired the Assassin's Creed team when
they were making Assassin's Creed 3 I'm
recording this on Wednesday and the
footage is still up on YouTube so I
imagine it's still up there no one seems
to be doing anything about it if you
want to go take a look it's super
interesting and as someone who
absolutely loved the signs of time I'm
kind of sad that this one never got made
but I think the bigger question is how
are people just finding this now you
might remember a couple of weeks ago we
had Greg Miller from kind of funny here
to talk about his fundraising efforts
for the American Cancer Society and know
we weren't disobeying social distancing
we do live together but great news is
that Greg and the kind of funny team
have made it to the finals of that
championship Tony and you can still head
over to kind of funny calm / Mizzou to
donate for a great cause now we open the
show this week with a clip from GTA
online so let's close out with red dead
[Music]
you know what this also reminds me of a
vine Colorado alright that's it for this
week's episode of good news gaming as
always if you have any other good news
stories stick them in the comments below
or come find me on Twitter I'm at Lucy
James games or DME for access to the
games for discord we have a lot of fun
in there right now I talk about mind
hunter so come in join the conversation
DM me for an invite I'll see you next
time
[Music]